let's talk about rigged elections for
weeks now maybe even months you could
say Donald Trump has been warning
basically setting himself up to deny or
not accept the election results of the
upcoming November 8th election by using
the term rigged election the entire
thing is rigged and as evidence for this
he pointed to the DNC having its hand on
the scales in favor of Hillary Clinton
and against Bernie Sanders during the
Democratic primary he pointed to some
media outlets that don't like Donald
Trump and he is arguing that the entire
thing is effectively rigged now
commentators having opinions is not
rigging an election gerrymandering you
could argue is sort of rigging an
election we talked about that yesterday
Hillary Clinton destroying you in three
debates that is not rigging an election
but voter suppression as we've talked
about is sort of rigging an election now
with the Trump campaign you're never too
far from either a lie or a hilarious
contradiction or double standard and I'm
gonna play one for you which is
Kellyanne Conway Trump campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway was interviewed by
CNN's Jake Tapper and although now she
is pushing to Donald Trump's claims
about a rigged election Jake Tapper
pointed out to her that just a few
months ago when she wasn't working for
Donald Trump
she called Trump's rigged election
commentary whining well what a surprise
good old Kelly Ann cut and yet another
Donald Trump campaign double standard
here's the video and as well let's talk
about the this idea that think
everything's rigged yesterday mr. Trump
once again arguing that the election
will be rigged it's a charge that he
makes with with no real evidence to
suggest it that many Republican
secretaries of state and others are very
upset that he is making now back in
April when you were working against
Donald Trump when you were supporting
Ted Cruz and advising his super PAC you
had some tough words for mr. Trump when
he was lashing a gout lashing out at the
time against the system being rigged to
go on we hear from the Trump campaign
rules the rules change is not fair the
system's rigged the system is corrupt he
can whine and complain
all you want that you didn't know the
rules is this a pattern with mr. Trump
if he starts losing he starts lashing
out and calling the system corrupt and
calling it rigged we love watching that
clip together but that was actually
about what was happening on the weekends
where Trump would win the vote he would
win all the basically all the electoral
votes in the state and then on the
weekends the Cruz campaign would go back
and follow the rules and get back some
of those delegates so no it's not a
pattern for him I think if you had
Hillary Clinton in this chair and you
asked her every hypothetical situation
possible would she would she respect the
results of the election what if just
hypothetically speaking since it
happened in 2000 out of 6 million votes
cast in Florida there was a difference
of 530 or so I like that
Jake you could come up with some insane
hypothetical where Hillary Clinton would
also say she wouldn't accept the result
I mean if you had Hillary in this chair
and you said to her hey Hillary if
Donald stole the election by hacking
voting machines and you could prove it
undeniably would you accept the results
and she would say no so yeah or
something and I like Pat how Kellyanne
says it's more of a weekend thing all
okay well just a weekend in the
elections on a Tuesday so it's a totally
different story
yeah SNL actually had a great depiction
of Kellyanne Conway when asked the
question she just rambles and yep you'd
it confuses the audience until the point
where they don't even remember the
question anymore yep and then tries to
pivot to Hillary Clinton or in this case
the 2000 election there's a politician
lies and then there's Donald Trump lies
and what Pat is getting at is that
there's delusion and then there's
Kellyanne Conway delusion which is a
complete dissociation from anything that
is on record as having been said it's
sort of like Mike Pence just denying
that Trump ever said any of the things
he said during the vice presidential
debate somebody emailed me saying David
Kellyanne is a nasty nasty woman child
channeling a Donald Trump's statement
about Hillary Clinton in the third and
final debate being an absolute hypocrite
did not even faze Kellyanne Conway in
that video that I showed you they do not
care and I like her passive-aggressive
dig at Jake
for will we just love watching that clip
together don't we Jake
the real difference the only difference
between her complaining about Trump's
rigged election claims and defending
Trump's rigged elections claims is that
her paycheck now is coming from Donald J
Trump that is the only difference and it
is yet another double standard